Leana Galera from Entertainment Tonight
here with the amazing Katrina balls and
Sam heughan we're gearing up for
outlander season two and so to celebrate
I think we should play a little game of
two truths and a lie
so Katrina you want to go first
sure tell me two truths a lie about your
acting career um I already I can tell I
did a film in German Arnold
Schwarzenegger was my father and I
worked with a bond so the first one was
you did a film in German we gave this
deal yeah that's this justice Clark yeah
yes is Lena Nam mine Annamma is the
Katrina valve and kevanna stuff uh yeah
bonus and yeah and the second almost was
the second one Arnold Schwarzenegger has
played my father hmm
did you can you do the catchphrase uh
and what was at that one uh I worked for
the balls you've worked with a bomb mmm
could be Pierce he's Irish Irish maybe
which one is it with one working good on
that line gonna say Schwarzenegger wrong
I mean I can't speak German Oh neither
can i all right Sam okay yes stint in
day right yes I'm ready okay all right
two truths and a lie well maybe about
these guilty pleasures I like to eat my
Ma's bar all the way around the sides
either end round the other side top off
first wat bit throw away the middle but
I like to go to the cinema on my own get
a bag of sweets sit at the back of the
cinema finish all the sweets I listen to
- - electronic dance music all hours of
the day and night and quite wrigley will
be found dancing around my house - all
hours
the problem is is that I've actually
heard some of that terrible music coming
from your train wouldn't say it was
terrible I mean it's a matter of opinion
I'm gonna go with the cinema and the
answer is yeah I'd say it was the line
yeah I do go to cinema on my own but
I've grown out the habit eating all the
seats yeah well done well thank you guys
so much for spilling two truths and a
lie
and for more information on Outlander
season to keep it locked to stars calm